olynyk none out of bio and butler the  remaining heat players out there  they lob it into butler poked away by  james taken by caruso  five seconds to go caruso to james james  back to caruso puts up a two-pointer  no good and the heat hold on what a wild  frantic finish  could have been such a costly turnover  but the miami heat  with a big win on the road defeat the la  lakers  96-94 that was some steal by lebron  james  that was a dangerous pass by andre  iguodala  but usually jimmy butler seals but  that's a different type of athlete with  different type of anticipation  [Applause]  james gets it a double team and caruso  just misses  we're talking about the upper body  strength of lebron to deflect it  and he makes the right play here  unfortunately caruso not able to knock  it down  so the lakers fall short